[Music]
you know the story neo otherwise known
as the one
is destined for greatness in the matrix
computer-generated reality
he eventually frees the world from
techno slavery but he certainly makes a
few mistakes along the way
from seemingly minor missteps to
world-ending decisions here are some of
neo's biggest no-nos
in the first installment of the trilogy
the agents offer neil a deal
if he cooperates and gives up morpheus
they'll let him go back to his regular
life
and wipe the slate clean yeah
wow that sounds like a really good deal
in response
neo gruffly asks agent smith for his
phone call well the agents don't take
too kindly to his uppity attitude
they seal his mouth shut with his own
skin and proceed to insert a truly
horrific device into his belly button
hey it can happen to the best of us of
course mr anderson
otherwise known as neo really is living
in a simulation but he doesn't know it
quite yet
being rude to the agents was a mistake
particularly since he had no idea what
he was really up against
beyond that his bad attitude might have
made the agents do something even more
drastic
sure neil was the hero of the story
which means there is no movie franchise
without him but he doesn't know that
does he one of the most complicated
aspects of the matrix is the fact that
everything neil does has already been
predetermined
that means no matter what movie makes
his path has already been mapped out and
free will is nothing but an illusion
something like that anyway
and things only get more complicated
when you stop to consider neo's
existence as
the one as you no doubt recall neil is
eventually killed by agent smith
but his death basically needs to happen
in order for neil to ultimately become
the one he dies then triumphantly comes
back to life
ready to embrace his lofty destiny it
becomes clear neil has evolved when he
manages to successfully
stop bullets with his mind and comes to
see the world in code
oh and at one point he manages to jump
inside agent smith
and explode him cool trick but something
of a mistake
we eventually learned that this act sets
agent smith free
making him a lethal computer virus that
can multiply
now agent smith is able to take over the
entire matrix
it is purpose that created us
purpose that connects us a purpose that
pulls us
that guides it that drives us smith
could have easily destroyed everything
and all because neo decided to be a
show-off and blow him up
the matrix series becomes truly
confusing when out of nowhere
neil finds himself at mobile avenue it's
a strange virtual land controlled by the
train man who works for the older
program called the mayor of indian
while the first movie managed to create
a world that was controlled by computer
simulation
the sequels changed the rules of the
game they add perplexing new variables
and otherwise scramble everything we
thought we knew about the world of the
matrix
what are you doing here you do not
belong here come on
goodness i apologize take mobile app for
example
basically neo is in limbo mobile is in
fact
an anagram of the word limbo the place
is evidently some odd hinterland between
the matrix and zion
the fact that neil followed his own path
apparently confused the system so much
that he suddenly found himself in a very
peculiar place
he's lucky he was able to make his way
out of mobile laugh but it's just that
total luck like so many of the other
parts of neil's story
ending up in mobile lab could have
easily led to his destruction
if neil doesn't take the red pill then
the end credits roll early
and there is no matrix trilogy that said
his reasoning for following the white
rabbit via the red pill
is well there isn't much of a thought
process behind the decision is there
without thinking he heeds the advice of
his hacked computer
the computer tells him to follow the
white rabbit and then
he sees the goth ravers tattoo of a
white rabbit and proceeds to follow her
this leads him to trinity by then
there's really no turning back
neil is clearly intrigued by these
people and quite frankly
he hates his current life that's
presumably why he takes the red pill
once morpheus offers it to him
remember all i'm offering is the truth
nothing more but if neil had taken the
blue pill he could have returned to his
life of blissful ignorance
taking the red pill means learning just
how corrupt the world
is and how little power he has which is
of course
necessary for him to learn and become a
hero
although it's admirable that he took the
red pill he basically makes the decision
on a whim
at the end of the day neil comes across
as rather naive
leaving us to wonder why he's so eager
to trust this morpheus character
remember when neil chooses the door that
leads to trinity in an effort to save
her
and he makes the decision despite the
fact that the architect
says choosing that door will lead to
humans becoming extinct
including trinity sure neil makes his
choice
but that choice nearly dooms the whole
human race
neil we learn is actually the sixth one
but his willingness to sacrifice
everything for love makes him different
from his predecessors
this leaves the future of the matrix in
doubt and it means neo is a rogue
program
after all neil is expected to open the
door that stabilizes the system but when
he decides to open the door that saves
trinity he goes totally off script
the move is heroic romantic and
ultimately the right thing to do
but you can't help but buck at neo's
choice it's a very bold move on the best
of days
you haven't answered my question quite
right
interesting check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you